hey just this a change of pace a little
levity this is kind of funny and
interesting many of you know that on
this program I've been smeared by
homophobic people for a long time
because I support LGBT rights we also
have funny stories like when producer
Lewis was the producer of the David
Pakman show I got an email from from a
gentleman saying hey David it's so great
that you and your partner are doing a
show together how long have you and
Lewis been together my husband and I
would love to have you guys over our
place for dinner and as funny as the
idea was of not telling Louis the
pretense and going over as they suppose
it coupled to dinner at someone's house
we didn't do that and I clarified Lewis
and I are not only not together we
exclusively date women I am personally
not gay but I support gay rights I'm a
straight Ally we've been straight allies
on this program for more than a decade
but over the years there have been both
misunderstandings and smears about this
so one example is that a few years ago I
was featured in a documentary called
Minnesota nice the documentary is about
anti-gay bullying suicides and that's a
horribly tragic subject but I was
featured as a gay teen who committed
suicide after being bullied and I had to
clarify I'm not a teenager I'm not gay I
wasn't bullied and I'm alive and it has
been brought to my attention that once
again there is a reference on my
Wikipedia page to a supposed
relationship with a man check this out
this was added to the personal life
section recently saying quote in
November 2015 Pakman moved to New York
City breaking up with his long term male
partner which coincided with a
relocation of the David Pakman show his
production this one is subtle but
someone did add a note that said
citation needed apparently they realized
there was no citation for that claim and
they've not been able to find one
because it is a completely bogus claim
so it would be inappropriate for me to
go in and edit the Wikipedia page the
subjects of wiki pages aren't supposed
to edit those pages themselves I think
that makes a lot of sense could be a
conflict of interest but I'm asking for
your help to update my Wikipedia page
and also help expand it I feel like it
could be far more robust based on what
the david pakman show has become over
the years this is funny in a way but the
obsession with smearing me as a gay man
is not only sort of getting boring I
don't actually understand the obsession
with it like what is so appealing about
that maybe somebody can explain it to me
sunday is my birthday we've got a huge
membership special all right police came
to my house yesterday and they said we
are not here to take any action today
but we heard you were planning a crazy
membership special on Sunday just know
we've been made aware of it and we're
going to monitor in case the special is
too deep of a discount Sunday get on our
mailing list today at david pakman.com
put in your email address on sunday you
will get an email with this incredible
incredible membership special make sure
you're following me on twitter at deep
hackman we'll take a quick break and be
back right after this